I got to hear 20 stories
now the Church of What's Happening Now
is presented by on
it the Church of What's Happening Now is
thrilled to introduce you to
Zeal Zeal is the app that brings
massages right to your door triy out
Zeal that's z e l right now and get an
25 $5 off of your first massage to do
that you're going to enter promo code at
checkout you can go to zeal.com or they
have an iPhone and Android app go to
zeal.com and to promo code Church to
checkout to get $25 off of your first
massage show is also brought to you by
hellotushy.com
the days are back the church what's
happening now is thrilled to introduce
you to hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt completely clean
with water sounds too good to be true I
love it go to hellotushy.com right now/
Church to get 10% off of your order
that's hellotushy.com Church to get 10%
off I'm happy you're
here you were just going to sit there
[__] anyway give me some volum there
Le
s it's the Church of What's Happening
Now Wednesday February 1st
[__] what happened to
January oh
[Music]
[__] oh [__] just when you thought it
was safe
[Music]
[__] leis
sayat EST
Co Joey Diaz the diversity
crew in the
[Music]
house are you [__] kidding me or what
we here at
church at the [__]
[Music]
Church what's your bench made out of is
it who's your favorite
crer oh
[__] we
church I'm forever there
yeah what's happening you bad
[__] Uncle Joey here direct
from the Voodoo
Lounge with his favorite nephew Lisa at
and his favorite niece Esther [__]
cuckoo and the [__] house
direct from Miami Beach man Uncle Joey
Diaz Miami Beach Miami Beach that's
right in these zika streets oh [__] oh
[__] I brought you I brought you a
couple vials of some zika what is that
call zika vaccine in case you want to
impregnate anyone you know throw that
throw that Joey Diaz superpower star
G Latin I was watching this News segment
of this pregnant lady she was outside
and the news people were at her house
she's endangering her baby and herself
by doing this stupid News segment for
what just so people can Facebook you I
saw you on TV stay in the house with the
[__] Shades drawn and [__] she comes
out with the cameras at her house going
yeah I don't leave the house much I'm
like [__] you're outside right now
outside get in the [__] house risking
this there's a zika mosquito somewhere
getting your baby it's [__] crazy
that that shit's going to that is like
that's going to affect our life like
when's the zika movie coming out like
when is when is too soon they already
have how long do you have to wait
[__] sci-fi already got a [__]
movie with that blonde chick what's her
name the chick Scarlet Johansson no no
no no the beat up one the one that was
in shark NATO terara Reed Tera Reed and
she goes on vacation and the [__] uh
bugs crawl in her purse and then she
opens up the purse they all fly out of
the party oh shark NATO no no with zika
NATO what is it called this is going to
be her with this [__] sci-fi
ziko she goes to [__] Brazil she
comes back she opens up her luggage and
all these mosquitoes fly out and bite
everybody in [__] Brentwood and
that's it nobody's killed more people
since OJ would you rather get killed by
zika or sharks I don't [__] know I
hate those type of questions I just want
to not be bothered you know what I'm
saying yeah I don't want people asking
me creepy questions like that speak I
know I'm really creepy speaking of NATO
you you're from Miami I don't like I was
talking to a friend of ours who was down
in Miami during one of the big
hurricanes a couple months ago and she's
just like oh yeah the hurricane shutters
it's a
party that does not make sense like it's
almost like hurricanes out here
hurricanes I don't get how it's just oh
it's a hurricane party we all might die
and our houses might fall but it's like
earthquake parties here I don't have
earthquake parties you don't no well you
just don't like parties well we don't
know when an earthquake is coming it's
not like the new oh right no no no it's
like Miami my God it's not announced my
our friend went to Florida and when she
landed two days later that big storm was
going to hit she went to some she went
she went to her family's house and
they're like what are you worried about
we got beer we got reefa we shuted the
windows we're going to have a party it's
like a snowstorm yeah it's a party it's
a snow day ain't nobody going to work
tomorrow right so [__] it let's get
[__] up and see the devil what we
going to do run from my houses the worst
thing going to happen is a power going
to go off perfect
perfect power goes off that means
somebody gets kissed is not supposed to
you know what I'm
saying or molested or molested it
depends on your point of view well
depends how many beers you had depends
how many if you're the the victim had
mest or molest it's [__] crazy what
do you want to do you want to sit there
in horror play Scrabble think about how
many things you've got into and they
haven't been as bad as you thought they
were going to be and
how did tropical storms how did I [__]
my head up so much into thinking this
was going to be so bad the same thing
happens because television the media the
media tell you those first off those
weather men are 50/50 they're 50/50 on a
good day on a good day they're 50
[__] 50 this [__] guy here Dallas
Reigns that dude is always wrong I like
when he gives you what time stop stop
don't tell me the time [__] he always
says about 1:00 storms will be coming no
they're not no they're not not they're
coming in the four I could tell you that
when I wake up in the morning look at
the [__] but I I went to a hurricane
preparedness meeting and I learned a lot
what did you learn I learned the safest
place where do you think the safest
place to be during a hurricane in your
basement no Florida doesn't have
basement it's all swamps underneath so
where's the safest place to be you go in
the bathtub and put a mattress over you
that's right in the bathtub that can
save your life tornado you go in the
basement but a hurricane because all
these trees are gonna fall and your roof
is gonna fall so cover something what's
the biggest object in your
house right in a natural disaster a
mattress what else they tell you you got
to pack food and [__] they have yeah
they have all this food that like like
Army Food where you could just like add
water add water yeah and and these meals
prepared to go meals there's like an
acronym for them I forgot what it was
MREs right yeah meals ready to eat yeah
like that's what the Army uses I have an
earthquake kit I mean it's I got I did
it when I first moved here they sell
them people got me so worked up when I
moved here water what's no I I have a
water bottle that has a filter in it
just so I do have water in my house but
I have a water bottle with Filter I have
am AM radio solar powered radio uh I
don't know if I have that I have uh
clothes I have some batteries I have one
in my car and I have one in my houses
but I haven't changed it it's in like
six years so I have like six-year-old uh
granola bars in there I don't even
really but I don't know I like when I
first moved here I was terrified of them
I was terrified of earthquak I was
terrified also but then I looked at my
Uncle my uncle's lived here since 19
[__]
60 you know something like
1960 you know he's [__] he doesn't
have doesn't need scars from hurric
earthqu from earthquakes no I I'm not
scared because when I first came to
California when I was 12 I had an
earthquake there was an earthquake here
when I was here for 2 weeks what year
was when you were 12 what what year was
that it was like
1994 yeah yeah northri 93 I mean no no I
mean it wasn't it wasn't a big
earthquake it was a tiny one tiny one so
that's why I'm not scared of earthquakes
because I've never seen I've never been
in like a crazy destructive one yeah
yeah just they've been saying for years
we're going to have a destructive one
here and you wake up here every morning
you do the best you can all I pray for
it's not in the middle of the [__]
night when you sleeping and trees are
going through your [__] thing and you
the the ground opens up and swallows you
while you're [__] sleeping that's a
as long as you're in one of those blocks
where you're living on a flat block how
much damage can it do unless you know
it's the one the houses that are on the
Hills that I think are scary during an
earthquake those [__] started
falling three nights ago uh debie lov's
house no dur during the rain somebody
the other day on Laurel Kon had a close
it's closed she she just bought the
house for 8 Ms she didn't even move in
yet $8 million house hasn't moved in yet
and the house Demi lado one of those
Demi Lavado or the other one kind of
cute singer I I don't really sounds the
side of the [__] Mountain went down
holy [__] in her front yard get
insurance before she bought it I don't
know I don't know it's five five people
live on the Block so wow there five
houses on the block all of them pretty
much got they can't go in and out of the
house that [__] petrifies yesterday [__]
that [__] all those houses Laurel Canyon
when you're going downhill and they're
real close to the road uh-uh I don't
give a [__] if they want $10 I'll buy a
house in Detroit before I before I'll
buy a house up there yesterday there was
a fire on the sidewalk from a gas
pipe just like on the street where just
I don't know somewhere in La I don't
know where I was but you saw it I saw it
okay like the the ambulance came I mean
the fire trucks came and we were all
like what's going on it's so loud and
the sidewalk was on fire and it would
not go out it was a little flame it was
like this big like a tiny cute little
yesterday some [__] dude stabb three
dudes the Jack in the Box right there on
Sunset by by we by amiibo that's my
[__] Battleground God damn it you how
many times I walked on that [__]
Street when I saw him at the corner
swipe at the chick they got the video of
him swiping at the white chick and her
running backwards and then he went into
a he went into a Jack In The Box Lee
aren't you happy went a Jack In The Box
yesterday at lunchtime well that's where
I was when I went to uh whatever it's
called Rosco and I was walking on that
block so that's [__] it's scary and
like a couple month like it's just
getting weird out there like that guy
who just killed a girl with a shotgun
remember that a couple months ago on
like sunset or Hollywood Boulevard oh
yeah yeah yeah in broad daylight yeah
just in broad daylight came up to a girl
and just shot
her and then they found out something
crazy like so he worked with her he had
quit the job something then [__] just
listen man that's the type of [__] that
makes you think to like if I was single
I didn't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
but with the baby and my wife they walk
to the zoo Sometimes some guy's just
there stabbing mother if you're single
you should give a [__] I I wouldn't give
a [__] about me I wouldn't give a [__]
you know what I'm saying like that
that's what I'm saying like I wouldn't
really be concerned I go you know what I
got to pack a gun I got to get a
bulletproof vest that type of [__] but I
guess that's why guys get married so
that you could give a [__] no it's it's
a it's a weird expression like I
wouldn't really worry about it that much
you know like I wouldn't really even
think twice about it but you you start
thinking about all the people I know in
Hollywood that walk
around that walk the [__] around
Hollywood that live over there shraer
that shreder Kena you know many [__]
people work at that CNN building and
walk up that hill every day to go to
that [__] burger joint and the taco
joint join and Joe's Pizza you how many
[__] people there's 12 floors
there I can't imagine do do you guys get
dark a lot like when you're just cuz you
guys are so you're comedians you
everyone would think you're funny and
happy going whenever like if I'm driving
and I whenever I've talked about this
but the the ramps from Highway to
highway I always think those are going
to fall on me or I'm going to when I'm
driving over them they're going to fall
I I just go I go dark immediately I
think the worst thing is going to happen
if someone doesn't call me back I us I
used to think like that oh yeah and I've
been training my mind to like not do
that to to to sort of like not let my
fears control me because I've let my
fears control me since I was a kid and
now I've made a big shift
mentally that's the cool that start
hitting you yeah yeah it's [__]
hitting you I can tell wait are you
serious how much does this have those
are the 200 migr ones which ones did you
give me these ones right here let me see
see the label because 125 I asked you
how much how much how many milligrams
they are and I swear you said 25 125 125
yeah is that a lot it's uh depends what
you call L that's a lot I think 10 is a
lot for me depends what you call a lot
we took like 2,000 we took like 2,000
but
we're we're in training you know what
I'm saying Jesus Christ we're taking it
to a different level when you start
talking about fears and [__] I can tell
that star is hitting me you're getting
all [__] K Manu on me
[__] it's Kum Manchu you're all [__]
foring cookie out and [__] it's Kum Manu
ah but yeah no cuz sometimes your fears
can come to life in your real life oh
[__] they always do they do Le that was
one of my biggest fans I mean little Jew
[__] how's your eye I remember you were
like oh the last time we got jauz
fingering your butthole and rubbing your
eye at the same yeah he's disgusting are
you okay are your that disease up at the
[__] that was his last day no no ask
him about his last that was my that was
my first impression no that was she was
there the last time I was at the S point
I don't I don't know if you were there
the first time should scoot over I don't
want to have get what you have no I
don't have anything anymore then the
second time he went carry the
virus poor [__] Le there's something
I never had any sort of skin issues I
like when you huff and puff well that's
because he gets me all worked up he
tells me I'm not going through training
and I have I take Edibles now someone
emailed me like you essentially have a
heroin habit take a break take a break
but I was I take it and he just tells he
he he likes to mess with me and he knows
he's messing with me that's why you're
here ah [__] people take a break they
don't know nothing those are the same
people that quit everything in their
[__] life we're not quitters here we
go deep into the murky Waters we're not
quitters we're
[__] absolutely so how you doing as
I'm good how are you
I'm doing really good I uh I was talking
to someone yesterday the other day and
he was saying that luckily he doesn't
think that the uh the edible doses are
going to go down he thinks you're going
to get to keep your medical card in
California which I'm pretty excited for
it's a I don't know who gives a [__] I'm
to eat those [__] things every day
they're supposed to shrink them to 10
nobody really knows it got voted in and
nobody's then you just got to eat more I
listen it doesn't even affect to make
people fatter doesn't even you're going
to eat more anymore just to get to that
2,000 than you can in a concentrated
thing it doesn't even matter to me
anymore I wonder I wonder if like the
calls to 911 call centers have gone up
since these Edibles have become so
readily available around here probably
right probably I know [__] we've had
three people that were in here that went
to the hospital and [__] like that oh
really who one of your guests yeah two
what who two of our guests had a boogie
and one of them just got up and walked
out during the podcast no way he walked
around the park Barefoot for like two
hours he didn't know where he was Brody
Stevens no bro Stevens is Legit to Quit
Jack no I'm kidding yeah bro stev Legit
to Quit aah AA got sick a Rodriguez AA
was really cool aa's Dynamite I've known
AA for years and we were sitting talking
and I left the stars out just the way
they are there and during the
conversation she just reached out stuck
a hand in and took one and there 40
minutes later dog I just saw a [__]
change you know oh my God it's really
weird sometimes people come on the
show and they eat a star and I'm sitting
right here next to them and I could see
the star grip them like esou I could see
like they ate the star and they've done
Edibles before and stuff like that yeah
was like I think because of the light
and the way we are and the way the light
hits you because the way you ever eat an
edible Go on stage yeah it's a different
animal every time I open for you once
the adrenaline gets cooking and [__] and
it's a fun thing to do look at pole he's
going through changes right now I'm just
thinking about all the time I went
through changes yeah oh my God so uh she
ate it and I could tell like a half hour
40 minutes I could tell her demean and
she was fine when she left but once you
get in that call and you start feeling
your heartbeat by yourself you're like
oh
[__] I got to go to the hospital you
know so I mean that's the thing a lot of
people aren't prepared for you smoke a
ton of weed you live in Miami you used
to weed exra I rely on weed to exist
yeah so yeah this ain't going to do
nothing to you it's maybe I should eat
some more no no no no no if you if if if
in an hour you're like Joey you're an
[__] okay yeah
let's you weigh 100 lb that's go with a
rock in your pocket so you know I didn't
mean to fakely dose you you know you're
ahead anyway I thought you good I
thought you were good for like 125 cuz I
know you're a professional you know you
do Doug show you smoke with them so I
thought you were professional I am I
just I'm not I don't do Edibles so often
how is the weed seen in Miami is there
Edibles more expensive than here it's so
cheap out here really oh my God you guys
are so lucky because they bring it from
here down there and they charge you or
they bring Canadian weed down there and
they tell you it's some Cali and you got
that going on too and there a biged on a
plane
you know you ever smoke in the bathroom
plane yeah you do once once two three
times what happened virgin caught me the
buzzer went off but they couldn't smell
it so they didn't do nothing was it a
vape yeah yeah same thing they smelled
it no they couldn't smell it so I was
like I don't know what happened and they
were like oh sorry they apologized to me
and then would they say anything to you
at the end of the flight no nothing no
cop waiting for you nothing did you feel
like they were watching watching you
after you got caught cuz I they were
watching me I broke my pen and half and
gave it to my wife to hold and and I go
give it back to me I put it in my bag in
the Sleep happing machine I threw mine
in the in the garbage can in the plain
bathroom and I like left and went to my
seat then when I realized they didn't
suspect me of anything I just went back
and grabbed it yeah they that that that
vape and Mak I thought somebody told me
it didn't I found out the hard way when
them banging on the door and I had like
a earone on so I had music on I'm
[__] stoned to the gills I'm peeing
I'm peeing everywhere I'm [__] up I
take my vapor pen out next thing you
know I hear Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom
what are you smoking in there open the
door I open it like what happened like I
know I go you know what the plane Shi I
bumped into this thing over here is that
what it is like no no no okay no problem
but that's how they nail you when you
land that's when they say something to
you they hit you with a buy the away
like I've been
stopped when I landed a couple times
cops have come up to me and said H we
got a
problem
but that's racial profiling no no no no
no I've gotten into beef on planes oh
okay it's my racial profiling nobody
racially profiles me they don't even
know what the [__] I am they look at me
they think I'm Italian look at the ID
Diaz they go we don't even want to know
go ahead enjoy your day you got weapons
no you got drugs no go don't want to
know that you could be in the witness
relocation they think I'm in the witness
relocation plan I don't know how many
people that I've looked at Witness
Protection Program yeah people think I'm
in the witness protection why because I
look Italian with a Spanish [__] name
not just like so you look suspicious
there no no no no no no no no no no no
there's no suspicious here they just
think that I'm like I had a guy tell me
one time God you're in the witness
relocation plan at a comedy Hotel next
time somebody sits next to me on the
plane and asks me what I do I'm going to
say I'm in the witness protection progr
n why would why would you say that and
he goes cuz your name is Jose
Diaz but you look like the guy from The
Sopranos that's crazy you do look
Italian so like a lot of you play
Italians in movies right who the [__]
know yeah I don't play Spanish roles at
all never I don't think you look Italian
I think it's because of your voice when
shut up Lee he looks Italian when did
that start though you're you're well I
guess it's it's not even Italian it's
just like New York and New Jersey yeah
that's inter you'd be surprised how many
people have said to me
especially when I've traveled to smaller
towns like uh an Arbor Michigan you know
why because that's where they put those
people oh in a college town they put
them any they put them everywhere they
put them right listen a college town
would be funny how [__] crazy is this
because college kids are so
self-involved they would never look at
at a wall of at a post office and be
like that guy looks like him how about
the feds put a friend of mine that the
Cubans were looking for in Fort lale and
they live peacefully for the rest of
their life the Cubans are right in Miami
they were looking for them and the FEDS
put these people in Fort Lauderdale in
high school the whole [__] thing wow
all right Fort Lauderdale is not that
far no because they put them right there
in your
backyard you're looking somewhere else
and they're [__] you know in
that was a very rare Cas minutes like
Henry Hill I don't know where the [__]
they took him at first he went to
Tennesse but you stick out like a sore
thumb in those places yeah you stick out
so they have to put you got you got to
shuffle it they have to put you
somewhere where you could mix in where
you would never suspect them to be when
you least expect
it that's a weird uh thing to just cuz
you you've gone on the run before but to
have someone tell you that you have to
go and that you can't talk to anybody
what do you mean the witness relation
yeah or just I mean being on the run I
mean cuz you can talk about that cuz you
can't you can't call anybody I had to go
to karate this morning with my daughter
she got a belt promotion and one of the
other kids in the class is a Cuban kid
he's Cuban and something else like
Iranian or something like that real cute
kid the mother's Cuban the father's
whatever but he's an FBI agent
so we got into a conversation
today into a mild conversation just
about generalities where I was from who
I grew up with and we started talking
about the FBI when they first got Sammy
the
burao when they first got Sam
buano the
FBI wanted John Gotti so [__] bad
stop fidgeting Le the FBI wanted John
Gotti so [__]
bad you ready for this one mhm they made
Sammy the
Bulls lone shark
collection the FBI collected his loone
shark
payments before Sammy the bull fully
went into the witness relocation
plan he was making 60,000 a month in
loan shark payments and he refused to go
in until all that debt was collected
he hit like 1.5 million on the street or
something still and he made the FBI go
collect the debts for him he would call
the [__] people
up were the FBI doing that on the side
or as their job as their job they
wanted him so
bad couple weeks ago I went down to
Tempe Arizona and I went for a walk one
morning and I was like
when [__] Sammy the borano first left
New York and he lived in Brooklyn you
know the five barrows he lived in
Brooklyn he was a captain in Brooklyn or
queens or something like that no no he
lived in Staten Island but he worked out
of Brooklyn and then you know when he
first flipped on John Gotti they took
him
directly somewhere else but where they
settled was Scottdale
Arizona and he was in Scottdale he
opened up an Italian restaurant called
The Olive Garden no and it was called
the best kept secret in Scottdale wow
that was the the jingle on the book of
matches and stuff no way it took him
years to find but remember Sammy didn't
give a [__] Sammy went right out there
and started telling people who he was he
opened up a pool cleaning
business they were going to go down
there and get them and then they hired
Chicago Police Department
cops from Chicago to go down there and
shoot him but right before they got down
there he got arrested by the
feds for ecstasy his son was involved in
an ecstasy ring since he had knowledge
in the whole thing he got arrested okay
they put him in jail in
Scottdale all right but there's this
[__] dude in jail in Newark New
Jersey who's doing these
documentaries and he's telling all these
[__] stories and [__] about the
people he killed I think the first two
documentaries were real I think after
that he just started claiming
everybody like he he would claim [__]
anybody but it doesn't matter one of his
documentaries the last one he spoke
about killing a cop in Jersey and they
said to him who gave you the order and
he goes the
gambinos when they interviewed Sammy the
bavan when he turned himself in you have
to tell him everything and
everything I don't give a [__] if you
ran over a cat you better [__] tell
him because they can't come back to
haunt him so during his interviews they
kept asking him we'll give you leniency
but you better not have killed a
cop the order for that
guy to kill that cop came from Sammy the
bull
Grano the feds right away went to
Scottdale took him out there charged him
in Jersey and put him in Colorado and
Tomahawk he's under the [__] jail
he's in the jail in Tomahawk that's
underground they built it in Colorado
for the worst people that's where the
terrorists are that's where Carlos Le
there is because he lied because he lied
because he embarrassed the feds cuz he
told he he was the see he was the first
one that really went in there so he had
his way not only that but he cond them
he told him he was never involved in
drugs and then people started turning
themselves in and all they all had
stories my partner was Sammy you're
lying Sammy was not involved in drugs
gone all these people got thrown out of
the program because Samy had lied he
said he wasn't involved in drugs but
these people all when they went in they
said I sold [__] ships for the
Quaaludes with Sammy what the [__] are
you talking about
so they got pissed at him for that they
still have him under the [__] prison
I mean but if you're getting caught by
the feds you're going to
lie not if you turn yourself in and cut
a deal who's going to turn themselves in
Sammy did would
you at that situation Sammy the bulano
they played tapes and the FEDS doctored
the
tapes and they made
Sammy look like a
killer so they were going to throw John
Gotti in jail for 50,000 years but they
were going to throw Sammy and jail in
there with him too listen all this audio
evidence right is garbage you can't
trust it anymore nowadays any a teenager
can just edit audio on their computer to
make it look like sound like how crazy
is that that it's crazy that doesn't
hold up in court anymore when you got a
greater attorney he actually high is f
FBI people to reexamine tapes that the
FBI examined for for evidence and they
find all the [__] inequalities in the
tape once you throw that tape in if
there's a big money attorney he's going
to call for an investigator and he's
going to hire a next FBI sound guy and
he's going to come up with it's a
[__] scam it's a scam in other words
it it makes you spend more money on your
defense so now it could attack you from
a different way way so it's a lot of
different ways with you know if
Scientology takes you to court they
string you up in litigation litigation
means you're spending money they got all
the money to keep you tangled up they'll
just keep sending their attorney 5,000 a
[__] day how long can you do 5,000 a
day for geez two weeks and you're
tapping
on
damn you know the witness relocation
program I read a book years ago named
witc
20 years ago when the Miami Improv was
on the third floor mhm towards the back
there was a boorder of books and as soon
as I would go pick up the key to the
condo I would go in that thing and buy
two or three books it was my [__]
addiction number two to cocaine I hate
going to library I hate buying books
I've been read already I don't like
buying fresh books I don't want your
greasy [__] disgusting fingers on my
[__] book or the pages are just more
brittle at the library so I read this
book wit that and it had stories of 10
different people they didn't even give
their real names but how they had really
succeeded
man they had really [__] succeeded
like you know there's some people who
going into the witness relocation plan
if you look up the statistics for what
the uh failure rate is it'll blow your
mind you got to assume the feds a line
about that too I guarantee it's
50/50 because you can't take the animal
out of person that's the
cool when those people go to that small
village didn't they take that red out of
that guy's [__] on jackass I don't
know nothing about that I don't watch
that [__] I'm talking about realities of
life here I don't know about jackass or
rats you ever see the movie My Blue
Heaven no you ever see it no no why
would you why why doesn't as get in
trouble because that's the is EST you're
you're from Boston be a shot and
H so what what should I look up for
witness relocation failure statistics
for witc program and see what the
[__] failure R is I guarantee it
would blow your mind and they're going
to dope it up but I read like 11
different stories that's the point is of
people who had
been uh what is that when I say that you
murdered somebody F fraud yeah F no no
no no nobody gets falsely [__]
accused here I'm talking about when you
murder somebody right but I murdered six
[__] so you know go I was there when
he murdered Lee plea agreement plea
agreement no no no don't confuse any
more whatever Al
so I don't even know what the [__] we're
talking about now cuz both these got to
[__] throw me off like stereos and
[__] you know I'm high you know I'm
barely holding on here to [__] memory
and [__] like that and you got to throw
something out like my wife to throw the
whole [__] Battlefield off sometimes
I'm sitting there I'm ready to leave the
[__] house I got something in my hand
and she'll say something I get in the C
Halfway Around the Corner because she
said something to me on the way out I
forgot the whole [__] kitten
Kaboodle I'm getting old that's the cool
so the 11 people that went to these
places bro they started beautiful
lives wow beautiful lives like they
looked at each other and said that's it
if I do this uhhuh we had a guy in here
we had a guy in here that came in here
one time and did the church he lived on
Laurel Canyon I made I did one of his
movies he was the first guy to roll on
John Gotti for
heroin and do you want me to tell you
what his reasoning was to get out what
that he had two kids that were going to
be big time football
players like they were like sophomores
and they had already been hit up from
colleges and they let him out right so
no no no he took his kids he went to
Texas they became All State football
players and they went to the University
of Colorado under different names
wow I found it they're saying so what
they're saying is they couldn't wear
their own names on their jerseys no you
got to wear different name they're
saying that 177% of people have re Reit
is is that what you're trying to find
out is that because that's kind of a
failure right if you commit a crime
while on uh whitte it's 177% compared to
41% of paroli so it's less than parolis
but they're saying that uh 95% of the
people in the program are criminals so
it's no they're [__] ice cream people
yeah they're [__] criminals I don't
know I thought like I thought more of
them were going to be like the uh the
kind of witnesses where like I witness
something and I they're going to kill me
just because I'm a witness oh I see what
you said I I figured it was more than 5%
of that who know but it's uh I can't
believe you know multiple people who
have been put in that program God damn
man to just be thrown like like a I
can't imagine someone coming to my house
one day and being like you have to move
your entire
life that's so sad
I tell you all the time people get
involved with people they know [__]
about and all a sudden you putting
little chains in your pocket you're
living like you've never lived before
and you get blinded by this ether
happens every day in America it happens
every day
everywhere and know next thing you know
you're going on vacations you're buying
nice cars your wife is happy she's
letting you put it up her ass for the
first time in 15 years is that how long
it took no no no I'm just [__] saying
no no I'm just saying that this is what
everybody's happy everybody's sucking
this ether you're buying your wife
diamonds you know and all of a sudden
the [__] gets tight and all of a sudden
they come to your house you got a kid
that's five you got a kid that's seven
you've been hanging out with
criminals dead professionals you're an
amateur you did paperwork you moved a
couple numbers guess what those numbers
are going to get you and your wife 40
[__] years
and your kids are going to have to live
with your mother in [__] Chicago and
she's an alcoholic and your dad bites
his toenails so now what the [__] do you
do you got yourself in a bad
Jam what do you do EST coou you know
these people you know where they have
more money hidden you know where the
drugs are you call the feds and they put
you in Portland Oregon and you live your
life under Mr and Mrs [__] Joe
Smith and your kids have to change their
names their school records get as
sponged you know
everything is gone everything so they
walk in with
kids not everything is gone there's
something that they do that's got to be
weird the feds walk being a kid being
told can you imagine you can't go by
Joey anymore can you imagine your new
name
is it's it's a listen man nothing is
free I mean they don't go to jail per se
but you go to jail you go to your own
personal prison because you can't live
the way you did you can't go to the
places that they used to do you can
never go
home you can never go home you can never
contact your
family contact your friends from those
years you can't do nothing and maybe
maybe this is just in movies but that is
torture but listen to me they even had
percentages for people who make
calls oh to they oh okay they even had a
broke and this book they even had to
broke it down like the percentages like
it was a book about 10 different 11
different people but they also had
couple chapters in there about what else
happens to you in there how you get de
programmed they put you in a hotel for a
little while and then the kids get to
know the marshals and you know it's it's
[__] weird you live with 15 people
for the next 6 months and then they move
you you go to court they move you and
then you have to fly back for the trials
to to
testify Jesus and they probably put you
in a [__] hole they probably aren't
putting you in like like some nice ass
house well here's the deal here's where
the knock came in and if you look even
closer into it okay and the knock comes
in they and this book they had it broken
down because it even happens where
people go s after 18 months you know why
because you s a contractor for the first
year the feds pay you and they pay you
[__]
tremendously I'm talking about if F Co
was working in the real estate office
making 80 grand she get her you get your
attorney to good know at
125 and Lee you can make 150 so for a
year you're living high on the hog and
Omaha Nebraska
yeah and all a sudden one day they go
it's
over and here you are 36 years old no
[__] you can't use your
name where's your college
degree you just have to invent your way
you have to reinvent yourself how many
[__] people
know how to reinvent themselves three
out of 10 I know somebody who's trying
to reinvent themselves oh I know
everybody was Reinventing themselves
every day go boulev sign go to Twitter
but not reinvent yourself that way you
have to remove your past life remove
what's going to get you [__] up you
know because all right so you never
drank before guess what you miss your
mother you miss your dog you miss your
father you're going to start drinking
that's really sad no it's a [__] it's
a [__] it's what's the it's the best
of two evils it's both of them are
[__]
evil then I read the Henry Hill book The
One his daughter wrote his daughter
wrote a book and you have to read this
craziness they lived in 10 different
[__] places the last one being SE
when he married another woman under a
different he told so he married his wife
under Henry Hill but he married the
mistress under the [__] new name and
he moved her into the house what oh my
God you got to read this [__] she hates
her father says that half the movies
[__] that she did the research he
was [__] in heroin Jo you need a book
club what do you mean you need a book
club tell people what to read yeah tell
people what to read recommend a book to
them well my you know like my wife reads
[__] up [__] after [__] she reads and
then she reads in the [__] computer
and they touch a screen and do that I ha
allit read book I'm an old man I want to
read the f I want to smell those papers
Filipe gave me a great book see how
physically like how fast I'm reading it
when Felipe won last when Felipe won
Last Comic Standing Felipe gave me a
book called Esparza yeah the something
crew it was about heroin when the Jews
were selling heroin and the Bronx with
the Italians it was just Jews and
Italians and a few
Chinese and I tried to get the book it
was
$250 and the only place that had it was
a big library in La so I had to go down
there and read it and then Felipe found
it and gave the the the Pleasant
Avenue connection that's the name of the
[__]
book Pleasant Avenue
connection is that it
yep
damn
Felipe the Pleasant Avenue
connection oh [__]
boom that's a good book right now Bob
Lingus gave me a
book
that I'm
salivating I'm
salivating but it's got to be it's going
to be a week to read this book the book
is maybe five [__] inches of book
it's lead it's Jimmy paage three
different lives the guitarist and Lead
Zeppelin wow just looking at it just
looking at the book gives you
anxiety for so many different ways it
gives me anxiety that it's not like the
old days where I could just crawl into a
[__] couch roll up five joints get a
half gallon orang juice some
mmgs some crackers like a [__]
put the TV on but turn the volume off
and just start
reading smoke a [__] joint read
[__] six chapters get up stretch
drink some orange just eat a piece of
cheese smoke another half a d and you're
just sinking into leg's world just for S
just like you're you're him while
reading it I love reading in that level
now let me let me lie to you even more
like I used to read and [__] like that
and I enjoyed it I don't enjoy reading
when somebody gave me a [__]
assignment yeah it's terrible like my
seventh grade teacher the one who failed
me Mr kingwell that [__] used to
make you read a book a month and it was
an oral book
report so he'd just read chapters and
ask you [__] stupid questions I was
never good with comprehension you know
what I'm saying I never claimed to be
[__] smart I can read the chapter
three times I don't know what the [__] I
read That's the other thing if I really
get into a book I got to read it twice
cuz I don't know what the [__] I read so
while I'm reading it I got to read it
again I got to smoke you read it again
the whole thing like I'll read it or or
did you just I'll read the chapter twice
oh Page by page page by Page
okay but you know so from that I learned
I like to read when I look at a book and
go like that book right there the
Hollywood Henderson book that's a day
and a half of me that's a that's I start
at 11: and I go till 4:00 and then I get
up at 8:00 take a shower wash my monk
eat breakfast and go again from 10:00 to
about 1:30 amazing that's how fast I
could read those but I just disappear
like I don't want the phone to ring like
when you're reading the book and the
phone rings and it ain't worth the phone
call like somebody's calling you to say
hello oh don't you you filthy
[__] I'm reading the best book
in the world you want to call me and
bother me Hi how are you what are you
doing have you heard this new album
listen for me a favor if you consider
shooting yourself come [__] bother me
one de this [__] book and they're
just a Lon [__] just hanging out by
themselves they have no significant
other and they just want to bug you but
speaking of being lonely that's where I
really got inter rating in
prison oh yeah that's how I kept
myself jammed up a few hours here a few
hours there I can't tell you how many
books that's why I learned to read
George Perez said told me that in jail
is just real quiet cuz I was like is
there anything you miss about jail and
he's like yeah when people leave jail
everybody's talking all the time like in
jail you guys all have your own private
space and everybody knows it's like
don't bu I would go to the library I
would just sit in the library for four
[__] hours read the paper put a
notepad down make notes yeah the Library
part of a jail looks like the outside
world cuz it it's a library it's a
library it doesn't feel like a jail
probably but it wasn't [__] the
library of the
Americas were there bars in front of the
library door no no so you feel free you
just walked in you just walk in sign
your name grab a book grab a newspaper
you could check out a book you know you
could check out a book to your sell
bring it back in 3 days keep revolving
you know you could order books like if
they don't have the book you can order
it from a different prison like they
have a book at a month club type I grew
up in the library my mom my mom used it
as a
daycare [__] immigrants right she
would just brilliant she you're going to
start doing that no I can't do that [__]
she would just drop us all off at the
library and we'd be there for hours
she'd go grocery shopping she go do all
her errands don't get me wrong I've
tried to be a a j sequa type of dude and
I've put on my little hat with a feather
and I've gone to the library with a cafe
Olay raise your pinky in the air I can't
I can't do it yeah I like reading with
the Sun hitting you well plus the
library is just filled with a bunch of
people using the Wi-Fi using the
computers yeah I I like that it's turned
into a semi YMCA you live in LA you pay
all this money you sacrifice so much to
be away from your family let me tell you
something you grab your notebook on a
pencil and you go get a [__] ice
coffee you smoke a joint you get some
nicotine gum and you face the sun with
an umbrella over you in
LA to Fig you got 4 hours of writing
you're out there getting vitamin D why'd
you come out of here if you're not going
to absorb this this [__]
son you know how much energy the sun
[__] gives you when you need to write
you have any [__] idea when you're
reading how that warmth gets you even
more fired up when you're reading a book
and you're drinking a nice cold [__]
water or something when the sun comes
that's why I never like the library yeah
I don't like the library too much it's
too dark for Uncle Joey it's too [__]
dark for me I like to read in the sun
you know a little Sun hitting you in the
park with the grass you can pull some
grass out nice nice lay down lay down on
your jacket very nice yeah there's
homeless people in the park I don't know
what you're talking the park well please
leave I'm talking about Central Park
there's homeless people in Central Park
how many how many homeless people bother
you at the Park what park are you you
guys La has the best looking homeless
people there's so goodlooking I saw a
super hot homeless guy today look last
week for the first time ever I went down
to the Flower District down there I saw
things down there I haven't seen in 40
[__] years that's horror down there
where where I went last week with it's a
whole street F tents yeah tents [__]
people out there yelling naked people
running around the street with blankets
on like a apocalypse you know
everybody's talking about this zombie
apocalypse I swear to God when I pulled
into that place I got out of my car and
I looked and the first thing I saw was a
guy naked dirty feet box of shorts with
a blanket walking around with his hair
all [__] up with a cup looking for
donations I went over I gave him two
[__] singles I said get some
sneakers go do something you know what
I'm saying you walking around here with
a blanket [__] bare feet your feet
are ugli than mine what the [__] not two
minutes I saw another dude walking with
a
blanket it was 900 in the [__]
morning how cold can it be these people
walking around with blankets their hairs
all [__] up looking for food looking I
got two egg sandwiches I gave one and
then you give them food and they are
like what is it and they and then you
tell them it's no no no listen I bought
two egg sandwiches the Korean dude cut
them in half and there was two why' you
point at me I just said the Korean D cut
them in half like this I didn't point at
nobody I don't point at nobody I don't
know what denomination you are I don't
want no problems with nobody you know
what I'm saying next you know the yak
was just kicking down my door I'm just
saying you're correct but go ahead are
you Korean y oh that's why you know how
I can tell you're Korean how you have a
certain Beauty to you Koreans are the
really hottest of all the Asian girls I
think I know but if I said I was
Japanese you would be like Japanese
women are just the hot I used to a
Korean girl you say that to all the
Asian depending on what Asian because
guys do that Japanese chicks are in the
medium but they're [__] up in their
head somewhere they still you know oh my
God they're getting bombed who the [__]
knows what's going on with them then
Chinese chicks are too
smart you know what I'm saying like
Chinese chicks are just too smart even
talk to that Zuckerberg's wife is
Chinese and she's a doctor one the girls
at the daycare is so Chinese she talks
with
that when you talk to old schooles sound
effects yes she
talks yes we went to Chin 10 this
weet I I know she's very sweet this lady
I was trying to explain uh but ethnic
people in their sound Al wona she wasn't
buying
it she wasn't buying Ali Wong she was
too [__] Chinese she's still [__]
pissed about
something dude I can you know you have
to be able to make sound effects of like
to communicate with Koreans like if I go
to a Korean restaurant they don't like
it if I don't make those sound effects
what kind of sound effects you make just
like okay I have a question you know
like to to do like the accent a little
bit cuz they I feel like they give me
bad service if I don't do that cuz then
they'll think I'm Chinese or Japanese so
I have to show them that I'm Korean even
if I order in English you know what I
mean are there really uh have you tried
the menus for like only Korean people in
Korean restaurants or only like TR that
I can't because I can't read Korean oh
that's [__] up I know now how long
have you been in Miami for for a couple
years just a couple years yeah I'll tell
you was a witness relocation guy and
you're going to put this together the
guy that own
liquid did you ever hear that Club
Liquid in Miami no a nightclub yeah late
'90s early 2000s it was a Club Liquid
uhhuh and Monday nights was big black
[__]
cat all right they would give you condom
rings at the door and [__] like that
[__] rings and [__] it was crazy I mean
I used to work Miami Coconut Grove and
they would say that Mondays you couldn't
get flights from New York to Miami it
was impossible was going to Miami the
fat black [__] cat really yeah lines
whatever you know wow and I guess the
owner from there he was dating Madonna
for a while he dated Jennifer Lopez he
was slinging some dick This D damn but
he was down there because he had killed
somebody in Brooklyn when he was younger
Mna [__] a murderer oh yeah so he went
to my that was the Allure then he owned
the club oh did they know did they know
he was a murderer well when somebody has
a gun you know when you hug somebody and
you can feel a gun you know these girls
they don't know what he is so he built
up his reputation he started smacking
people he turned it into New York City
down there he brought his buddies down
there and then his he he got rich he got
[__] filthy rich Filthy Rich he was
opening up another club then the people
in the in New York found out that he got
rich and those barracudas shot down to
Miami to get their [__]
paper and somewhere along the line and
he turned a witness relocated guy
against the columbos but let me flash to
you you ready for this 4 years ago 5
years ago he had a restaurant on Melrose
just like
that I thought you were supposed to like
keep a low profile some people go in and
go [__] it I'm not going to do that let
them kill me oh my god
wow so he opened up two
restaurants read it his name is
Christian let's see what comes up what's
the name of his restaurant we're going
to find out right now there's nothing
suspicious going on here restaurant I
don't know Christian pachello p a c i e
l l o try that that's all I know I don't
even know what his witness relocation
name is I don't really know what it says
on there yeah uh let's see
here a former was he born in like' 70s
do you think pello okay he's a member of
the Untouchable car theft ring and a
government informant convicted of
murder and he became a prominent night
club owner in South Miami God damn it
what the [__] do you think they dealing
with some Nubs Jesus yeah he was born in
he was born in Brooklyn under a
different last
name and yeah he was on the he was in
the mob and a $300,000 bank
robbery [__] now did he have a
restaurant that say the name of the
restaurant and it said it went
under
it was always very interesting to me
okay he opened one in Miami called
Bianca in the Delano Hotel the Delano
Delano sorry oh damn he opened the
Delano he open it's called Bianca in the
Del Bianca the Delano a restaurant in
the Delano he didn't open up the [__]
Delano Delo was there when Tony Montana
got the [__]
Miami that's the coolest [__] you better
eat the other have for that start you
know what I'm saying yeah where did I
put it I don't know but we got tons of
them I thought he opened a Delano if you
open it if you [__] lose it we got
more I lost I lost a the half of my star
the other half okay which one should I
have 375 no no take the little one the
375 this is little right yeah the red
they got to be red not purple oh my God
yeah he also dated Sophia varara Naomi
Campbell Daisy Fuentes Jesus Christ he
slung big diick that means they all have
the same
STD probably you know yeah he was dating
Sophia VAV that's what he was dating
don't you think all these celebrities
they must be rabid with STD they must be
like [__] crazy [__] man do you think
like is there like a level that we just
don't get to see I don't know if it's
celebrity I don't know if it's political
but maybe it's just like for people with
that much money like how is Madonna
[__] a nightclub owner in Miami who's
on witness Rel look it
just that that whole world I don't think
we know anything well this was before he
wanted to wit this relocation plan he
opens up this club bro okay he owns the
hottest club on South Beach everybody's
going in there Puffy Combs everybody's
going every night of the week somebody
else is in [__] Miami shooting the
video and they're told to go to liquid
and they go to liquid it becomes the
hottest club girls come in everybody's
kissing on him and [__] who was he
dating yet Sophia varar Madonna uh
Jennifer Lopez I mean he had little flin
with all of them Nikki Taylor Naomi
Campbell Daisy Fontes you know what once
you get away with murder you could just
conquer the nclub world so he created
this Aura around him he's a gangster you
know what I'm saying yeah and again some
people don't know what they're getting
involved with until you get a knock on
the door at 6:00 in the morning your
parents are over there and that's the
FBI willing to talk to you about your
former boyfriend if he had a gun what
characteristics did he have and you like
I knew he was a gangster that's why I
sucked his dick you know what I'm saying
like what do you think I knew it I loved
it that's the ultimate bad boy yeah
until he he has like nine girlfriends
you know what I'm saying I didn't want
to be one of his
[__] so I found out my gangster
boyfriend is going out with 20 other
girls and they all look like me that's
yeah that's it do you think I should
break up with him yeah that's one of the
weirdest scenes in uh is it good
Fellas where like it's amazing how
quickly the the wife goes from like
getting money to shop and giving a
[__] in like the kitchen to mad about
the mad about the mistress and all it
like it's quick how quickly stuff can
turn from everyone's on board and yeah
that must be [__] about being on
witness relocation what if your wife
gets pissed off and suddenly wants to go
back and tell everybody and that's what
happened to Sam the government wants my
husband to be in the witness protection
program when Sammy the bull first went
into the rap
program his wife said [__]
you oh no his wife said [__] you I don't
want no part of you the neighborhood
don't want no part of you you're a
[__] piece of [__] once he got
convicted he went to Arizona she flew
down
and I'm your [__]
husband regardless of what happened you
got to take me in the good times and the
bad times it's part of the [__]
speecher gift correct or no yep right
something like that right so in good and
bad
I [__] up but in the meantime when I
was [__] up you were living like a
doctor you were smoking cigarettes and
drinking [__] Bay pan
and going to France you know Sammy the
Bull made a ton of [__]
money when I'm telling you tons of money
I'm talking about millions of [__]
dollars as a
gangster that's tough to do that can
never be done like he was selling drugs
he had construction companies he had a
he had a piece of the Union you know I
mean he was a lone shark he was in
charge of gambling that guy made a lot
of [__] money man he bought a lottery
ticket like you know like when you win
the lottery for 1.4 million and you
could do the buyout for 800,000 he
bought the lottery ticket so he could
cash it in and claim it on his
taxes that is brilliant [__] like that
that's that street [__] that's crazy oh
my God somebody hit the lottery three
time oh the dude from Boston that dude
hit the lottery like eight times why he
B bul you so wait what you're saying is
someone would win the lottery all right
you win the lottery buy it from oh my
God he but besides having to just buy
the lottery tickets he has to win a
couple times yeah so so he would buy out
the live Lottery yeah he's like and
throw away the other
tickets that's who's buying the lot of
tickets crazy the mob is fueling the
lottery industry it's [__] crazy and
they're all in on
it when I got
arrested I went
to when I got arrested you have to give
a
statement and I kind of conflicted
myself and then I shut my mouth and they
kind of used it against me but they
really couldn't cuz it didn't say that I
was
guilty but I play them like I got
arrested uh I turned myself in November
something right uhhuh and for what for a
bunch of stuff kidnapp aggravated but
they got plea bargain but I played that
am I being kidnapped right now no no
no uh I why would I kidnap you I got you
on a podcast unless this is a fake
podcast I got to kill
Lee I got I got to blow up the [__]
computer and then I you know what I'm
saying it'd be too much work it's too
many moving part too much effort there's
too much DNA you walked around Barefoot
I bleed a lot you don't want to do that
bleeds a lot some when you got AR I
walked on your back earlier there's foot
there's footprints on your T-shirt no
yeah remember Le dude these stars are
really getting to you Joey I know
they're getting to you that's go you've
already forgotten half of what we've
done today I know so remember we went to
get ice cream no I didn't so I played
like I didn't say a word uh they didn't
say nothing to me and nobody ever came
to me and said can we talk to you well
we want to know who you nobody ever said
nothing to me do you ever do you ever
have a cop arrest you who's like a tiny
guy oh they were all tiny so what did
did how many people does it take to
arrest you like I just turned around why
would I want to fight them they have
guns they got guns I'm in no mood to go
hand I've never disrespected a police
officer in my life like I've never
gotten really into a verbal altercation
one time that two days after 911 I got a
$450 ticket because my car was over the
line at 7-Eleven into a handicap
spotu and I looked and and I bro 450 I
felt 450 jeez 450 you feel 450 oh God I
looked at that [__] I said they
just blew up the towers and you give me
a ticket for five bills for being like
that was the first time I ever said
something out of color I've never had a
problem with a cop onto the station
nothing you come you talk to me I try to
talk to you like a man if we can't
figure it out there we take it to the
station so when I turned myself and
nothing nothing was said to me then
about mid
January beginning of February I got to
an argue with my attorney and I had to
go to court and fire him and get a new
attorney which also bought me time which
is what I wanted I would have fired 10
attorneys you know what I'm saying I
didn't give a [__] the state was going
to pay for them and then at the last
minute I I was going to throw I was
going to throw my own money in and get
my own attorney anyway you understand I
already had a master [__] plan that's
the yes I love it so in the meantime I
had already talked to the attorney I was
just trying to save the money I didn't
want to give this guy this much money at
this point I was going to try to hold
them off for another [__]
month but when I went to court he
couldn't show up that money it was a
Monday morning at 10:00 and I didn't go
up in front of the same judge that
prosecuted me I went in front of the guy
sentence me I went in front of this
other
judge and he goes do me a
favor uh I want to talk to you but not
this case but about your counsel meet me
in Chambers go over behind here I'll
have the sheriff bring you around there
and when I walked behind
there I was in this room and Al this
door opened up and the dude I turned
myself in with came in the room with two
other
dudes and then one dude had like a beard
and then one dude had was dressed nicely
was just a regular nerdy dude they
introduced themselves and they said
listen man you're looking at a lot of
time here uh the guy you got in trouble
with before he got bailed out he gave us
a bunch of information about you we want
to show you something did you believe
him no no no no I played it all I was
young but I had already been to the
grill yeah you knew what I knew yeah at
this time already I had come
in at this time already I knew I was
going a due time and I wasn't accepting
it too good but what was I going to do I
did did the crime this is for all the
other crimes I've done did the
correctional officers treat you okay no
no no by this time it wasn't
correctional officers these guys were
this is before I even got sentenced s Co
I'm still walking around the street I
had to go to court to fill a motion out
to file a motion to fire my old attorney
so when I was there in court the judge
says to me listen since you fire this
other attorney come around the back and
let me give you a list of something of
the other court appointed
attorneys my clerk will give you my
clerk like a a little old dude or chick
or something so when I walk around the
back before the clerk could come in the
cop that I turned myself into came in
with two other dudes and they said we
want to talk to you about something and
I'm like what's up and they're like
listen you're looking at time but we
were looking through our files and look
what we found they and they had pictures
of the house I lived in 435 far away
Road they have pict far away road that
was the name of the place in M Village
oh my God that's such a great name they
had all these pictures of me at the
airport they were saying that this is
going to be Federal time for what I was
doing that all they got to do is get one
of the plane tickets they were just
blowing smoke up my ass and they said
that I knew people in Boulder that I
could help him with and I go listen I
don't know nobody who the [__] do I know
you're trying to Convent me from
stealing Coke right if I know somebody
wouldn't I be stealing [__] Coke and
that was it they said we'll be in touch
you they never said nothing to me again
the clerk came out gave me the piece of
paper and I left and that was it I they
never beat me up it wasn't like the
movies where they're like uh you know
you have the answer you know who it was
they almost respect you yeah no no no
they didn't respect nobody they just
knew I wasn't saying nothing I didn't
know nobody you're not a troublemaker
listen if they were going to arrest me
in snowman Village they would have
arrested me that's where they [__] up
if they wanted me for something at that
time for drugs at that time they should
have pinched me right there while I was
in the [__] courtroom they didn't
that's the cool so when they didn't
pinch me that means they had nothing if
they had something they would have
arrested me since they didn't have
anything they just had a rat that didn't
wear a wire that they were taking
pictures of buying Coke from me
supposedly they didn't really have
nothing they were just assuming they
said I knew people in Jersey they
thought you'd be dumb enough to fall for
that no it wasn't that was O nothing off
the fall for
nothing
that was a tremendous fart it blew
backwards though I got to shake my
sweatshirt off I thought that was a
medium medium to small size fart oh my
God this is a crazy [__] show tonight
Le Lee one of the star sure why not what
the [__] it's Wednesday night February
1st does the hog come out the whole
tomorrow what's he going to do Groundhog
Day tomorrow is it really yeah February
2nd see I know it's Groundhog Day the
[__] you people think you're dealing
with joy bis you know we're it's
February you got to order something for
your wife for what for Valentine's Day
it's coming up Valentine's Day in my
house is every [__] day all right
every day at my house what Valentine's
Day every day at my house is Valentine's
Day Valentine's Day coming up every
[__]
day God damn I'm very happy about that
it used to not be Valentine's Day every
day but things happen people get
comfortable with each other and that's
it everything everything falls into
[__] place right we're not we're
we're comfortable now now that now that
you farted I'm I'm just not I'm just not
going to hold my farts in from the rest
of the podcast no no no no listen let
one of those Korean Zing he loves all
that stuff he'll smell that little
[__] dumpling ass until it's all over
that little dumpling fart I us I used to
tell my parents you can't move your
bodies when you fart like in America
people like to keep it secret who farted
in Korea they all announced their farts
like like oh they do yeah as a sign of
like I enjoyed your meal oh please I'm
like stop doing that man that's the cool
you keep telling me that you're working
on a project tell me I got to go to the
bathroom but tell Lee and I'll come in
mid conversation what you're working for
well I actually I actually farted
yesterday that's nice no okay well
here's the thing you know they
microphoned us and I had a microphone
here one of those lava leers right right
and it's attached to the battery pack
but you have it on all day so you forget
that you have it on oh so in the middle
when we took a break from shooting I
went to the bathroom and the sound guy
probably heard me peeing which is fine
I'm okay with somebody hearing me pee
right you've heard girls pee right all
the time and did you get a boner no not
not not recently it's fine so I was
peeing but while I was peeing I also
farted a little bit that happens to me
every day yeah but like not like even a
big one like not even an audible one it
was one of those like well I used to
work in reality TV so I or I don't know
if it's reality or not but um they like
we part of my job was to sync up all the
days like all the footage so like we'd
see them especially when they lived on
set we'd see them all day in the
bathroom all all that all that stuff but
I I've never heard I never saw anyone
fart like I never heard big
farts you never heard big farts no no I
think probably you uh they probably turn
the mics off if they know you're peeing
CU they probably don't want to listen to
it oh you think so yeah probably or or
maybe there are some sound guys who want
to keep it on well yeah and they and
they like it yeah well I'm sure there's
some sound guys but probably most people
turn it off oh I'll just tell myself
they turned it off yeah yeah they turned
it off yeah so so how what is the new
project about or whatever you can say
about it um well it's not a reality show
it's actually uh an all female sketch
show oh cool that's awesome it's so cool
I'm having so much fun and like when
they send us the scripts I'm like dying
laughing reading the scripts the day
before so for a sketch show are the
scripts
mostly like just uh premises for the
sketches and then you improv it or is it
all uh written out for you um a lot of
it is written out but they let us improv
also very cool which yeah which is so
good so it's for it's
for a did you go to the bathroom yeah
you took a [__] no I don't do that stuff
in public I got respect for people these
people that go in public bathrooms and
destroy that
[__] um but yeah it's it's for
seriously.tv oh very nice yeah so it's a
web series it's a it's a it's a digital
show it's amazing a digital sketch show
it's amazing
where Lee and I were just talking about
this
that maybe we should do a YouTube show
or something you know because I love the
net yeah I love the freedom of the
internet I'm too [__] old to go on
network TV and for them to say the word
you know you can't say that word you
know like I am too old dog yeah you
should produce your own
stuff excuse me I would definitely
consider it like I just shot this thing
for Animal Planet why I become like an
Anthony boura Cat I would go to
different cities and talk to different
cat things and learn and teach people
about different things like people
really don't know about [__] cats you
know how many cats you got a bunch of
them what's with the
questions so it's just uh you know I
like I like the show to work out you
know but in reality you know I say some
crazy [__] on Twitter it's not that I
plan it I go by feeling you know what
I'm saying hey we can't we can't control
what comes out of our mouths if you
leave me an opening I got to take that
opening
you know I was just listening to an old
tape from two weeks ago I was saying
some crazy [__] even leg go do you ever
go dark every day Lee I live in the dark
that's the only way to get creative for
guys like us that's what people don't
understand yeah we have to live in the
dark we pull ourselves in the dark all
the time so that you can enjoy a little
light you know they they they do all
these specials about the Dark Side of
comedy and the Dark Side of comedy
comedy gets dark when you add the leaf a
weapon to it
drugs okay Jerry Lewis didn't go killing
themselves all these people didn't go
hang themselves or kill themselves I'm
not putting any disrespect to anybody
you know Robin Williams was mentally ill
he he got
misdiagnosed and was prescribed the
wrong medication you know we think with
our heads we go crazy I go [__] crazy
by myself sometimes in the whole th room
I'm hitting that vapor pen like a Savage
you know all jokes aside but I'm reading
this book right now that I only have a
couple pages left in it it's I've read
it 10 [__] times I read it to
motivate me twice a year it's called the
uh war of art not the sangu one this is
a a Steven presler one
um a friend of mine turned me on to when
it first came out then a couple years
ago bur CA popped his head up and said
whatever so I went out and bought it
again I remembered it and it talks a lot
about fear it talks like when you were
talking about tonight conquering your
fear
resistance all this [__] uh stuff
that what were we talking about the war
of art the war no no Before the War of
art why did I The Art of War the war of
art there's The Art of War and the war
of art what's the war of art Steven
pressfield
what and he's a a guy that's that's a
writer he's failed writer and he writes
but he writes about this [__] that keeps
us from going where we're going you know
he talks about your day on the computer
you know he talks about how your rituals
you know that I just gave you $50,000
that's Theo you got to write this
[__]
book so you cancel the road work and for
a month you're going to write this book
so for the first [__] three days
you're basically going to sit there and
look at that page and then switch to
Facebook switch to your phone switch to
Twitter watch some porn you're going to
rent you're going to rent a cabin in the
woods in massachusett all that kind of
[__] yeah but he's trying to tell you
that if you sit down every day for two
hours and force yourself to sit down
that's what the the most important thing
I get in the book but the book is sold
to people like when he talks about it he
says this is for anybody who wants let's
every been on a diet or quit this is for
anybody who's ever been in an
organization and just quit this is for
you know saying like this is for people
who just sto doing what they love doing
because they didn't want to do the work
side of it they picked the easy Road
it's called resistance and we're all
triggered by it we all have it you know
what I'm saying we all [__] have it
until we get ourselves into a habit into
a swing of things is when everything
works out you know what I'm saying yeah
read the book it's a great book okay I
can't I don't know why I [__]
referenced it I got to drop book because
you're dark yeah because the the
darkness man listen I'm two different
people than who I was from 2007 to 2017
you want me to tell you why
drugs
drugs drugs you going to see red man
tonight I don't know you going to go to
he's at the store he's got a show at the
store oh yeah stop down here on the way
to the store say hello to Red Man tell
him to put you up and go red man do me a
favor here's my email send me the Joey
Diaz tapes from Vegas when he was
talking about he was
done look at those Taps and call me
tomorrow and go Joey I don't know who
that person is I don't know who that
person
is I have no idea who you were that
person talking that [__] that's a
complete different person that was 27
years of a beaten and drugs but the only
reason why I had gotten that beaten was
because of drugs are you with me
yeah that was the tail end what was the
strongest drug you were on at that time
I would go to Vegas all right with Joe
and we were flying Thursday night and
the first thing I do I had this number
to this
dude the dude had so much juice but
after a certain time in Vegas you can't
just walk on an elevator and go to the
18th
floor you know what I'm saying you you
ever stay on the ninth floor and you try
to come up and seear me and all sudden
they call me in my room Lee and I got to
call downstairs let Lee up and they let
Lee up cuz we're in two different sides
of the hotel oh it's the worst that's
what happened well this guy would just
ask you what room me at 1809 call me
when you get here W need to next thing
you
know I'd let him in this guy would come
in for1 $100 or something he gave me an
eight ball for 120 give me a come down
package two Viking a Valium and a Xanax
are you [__] kidding
me
I was banging out an a ball a night
Jesus Christ plus all the pills plus I
would buy extra [__] Zan I would come
home on
Sunday toxic green green three days of
no sleep maybe an hour here an hour
there I've jerked off maybe 64 [__]
times I even came a nut sped out you
know what I'm saying like my body was
building another nut like I would just
be a [__] mess I would stay in my
room with a notebook there was a time my
friends that that the weekend I made
that tape let me tell you what's even
sadder about that thing with red band
it's called The Joe
show this was Joe Rogan's reality show
that he was going to make everybody a
star with he was going to take us all
into network television with this thing
nobody bought it but him and red man
shot this and it was pretty [__]
creative for its time you know like it
was pretty insane it was five [__]
seven guys on the
road me Joe red ban Hari Duncan Tate
Fletcher Eddie
Bravo it was it was insane we'd pull up
and there'd be a van waiting for us at
the airport it was like a traveling boys
band so we would tape all these weekends
Duncan tapped out after all this is
crazy this is too much you guys eat too
much red meat no wonder you act like
animals you know it was crazy we taped
all those until it we just got down to
me Joe and redband on the
weekend and I'd been high two nights in
a [__] row I mean no sleep High
hiding from people but that weekend that
I tell you about we did the House of
Blues on Saturday I flew in on Thursday
night like I was like Jo we got to fly
Thursday he's like why I'll tell you in
the morning [__] you I didn't to nobody
he didn't see me till Saturday
night like nobody [__] saw me dog I
had friends in Vegas that weekend that
were visiting from New
Jersey that was staying at the Bellagio
something they called me 80 times and I
really like 10 calls I pick up and I go
dog I'm rehearsing I'm doing something
for the UFC can I call you when I'm
finished they kept calling me oh we're
over here eating dinner why don't you
join us give me 10 minutes I'm I'm doing
something for Robert goulay I was just
lying to them this is 10 [__] years
ago dog I would not leave that hotel
room
just
Paranoia by that point it wasn't even
paranoia it was disgust it was disdain
it was
[__] the worst it was the [__]
worst I was
powerless I was lucky I was showing up
the gigs I was lucky I was showing and
at that time I used to cancel on you on
Friday EST Co you wouldn't even know I
canceled on you till you got to the
airport and went to pick me up and then
then you'd call me have these have these
clubs had you back since then those
clubs are out of business don't matter
[__] them they get all suck and like
yeah the two or three clubs I did it to
are out of
business so I took a chance and I paid
off Slade's room and Pete the uh the
Houston both of them both of them were
waiting for me at the
airport wow I would get so [__] high
I'd get in my car I'd Drive to the
airport and then turn around and drive
home Jesus that's how crazy I was at the
end nobody would hire
me yeah it was a 50/50 chance I didn't
tell you how I felt though cuz I get so
[__] high sometimes it work on the
way back sometimes I get so high I
wouldn't come home till
Tuesday we were always wondering where
you were Uncle no no no you didn't know
me when I was crazy as me and Lee we
always like were're like [__] what
happened to to Uncle Joey this
Thanksgiving that's why remember that's
why it's so weird for me yeah because
now he's like a boring like
like I'll tell you I'll tell you it's
gone to the point I've known Joey for I
think almost six
years I could almost pretty much tell
you where he is based on the time of the
day day of the week like if I know his
touring schedule I know where he is for
this machine to work I have to live my
life
a certain way you guys have a well oiled
machine no no not this machine I'm
talking about for this machine yep for
this machine to work but listen I didn't
always know that you
know I didn't always know that it's not
like I was born 21 I was like I know how
this machine works nobody knows how that
machine works till you hit about 40
you've had a couple failed things things
haven't worked out and you figure it out
and every year you get a little stronger
Believe it or not you know I mean uh
that's the advantages of getting older
that you see the game a little tighter
you st cutting the fat off of your [__]
it doesn't take as much time to make a
decision right you know no no not
anymore yeah no not anymore but I still
weigh the facts hey man I've made
horrible
decisions without checking or Googling
or I'm one of those [__] yeah
whatever let's do it
it and you eventually pay for so many of
those mistakes you
know that's what being young is guys is
making [__]
mistakes I sit there every day and drive
my daughter my wife drives I sit in the
passenger seat like [__] an idiot and
my little four-year-old in the back and
once we hit the 101 before you can make
that right we go
straight and for 3 minutes Le I scammed
myself what do you
mean like what's she going to do with
her
life what happens if I die next year
how's she going to grow up is she going
to end up a [__] stripper a gole
dancer how did we get there from just
driving straight you talked about going
dark okay so you're just driving over
yeah I'm driving the sun's out it's a
beautiful day to be alive I just smoked
[__] eight Bowls in the backyard I've
been listening to music I had a protein
shake you know I'm driving my daughter
to [__] school who's better than me
nobody who's got I got the window open
my wife got Classic Rock on Fleetwood
macas on chains whatever the [__] it is
and all of a sudden my mind just goes
what she going to do with her life how
much is college going to be will I even
be alive to pay for [__] College
college is [__] and all a sudden you
don't need to go to college I understand
don't wor don't worry about college this
is the thoughts that go through your
mind and then you go what the [__] am I
doing why am I thinking about that stuff
you know what she's full she's going to
go through a thousand things in her life
just like I did all right and guess what
you deal with it and you do the best
that you can and you give them all the
love I love her with all my heart I kiss
my wife in front of her she knows
there's a lot of [__] love around her
and [__] the cat's lover her Lee comes
over we it's our friend it's our friend
we we come in let me show you the
bedroom you know [__] like that you know
so they uh get it but I still have my
dark thoughts about it yeah there's a
thousand what if you know right I gotta
be crazy not to go
there with what I experience in my life
you know what I'm saying I found my mom
when I was 16 I know how fast your life
could change from one day to another do
you think that thinking about it those
jinxing yourself sometimes I do no to be
honest with you I was raised not to
think about that stuff yeah that's what
I'm talking about yeah but
you always have to go dark from time to
time why just for five minutes just go
what if bam but then also snap out of it
snap out of it you know don't let it
consume you you just as soon as you're
there you're like okay hello darkness
hello darkness no no that's the that's
the that you were talking earlier I'm
quoting you controlling your
fear is turning off the darkness that's
all controlling the fear is the same you
got to recognize when you go dark so
that when you go dark you don't stay
there too long or else you'll be in
trouble and that that works in life
too what's up
Lisa look at [__] that's the anybody
need to fart no no I'm straight what's
going on oh oh [__] I [__] my pants in
front of Paula for the first time I
didn't [__] my pants but I apparently
had like a shitty day and I had like
some uh uh what are they called hery
stains or whatever and she saw them and
she's like oh [__] what are those on
your underwear yeah I've never done that
in front of a girlfriend before oh she
found them and your underwear yeah it's
okay don't worry about it she wasn't mad
she was cool about it I mean why would
she be mad like as if she's your mom
because wait till he finds what's in her
[__] underwear that yellow [__]
stain of death with that you know that
they have that cat piss women that
little p is [__] yellow is De
sometimes and [__] especially if they
eat [__] cheese oh my go you know you
know what you know what feels good
getting smoke literally blown up your
ass well listen I don't need to know
that's have you ever gotten that done
ask her to do that for you no I haven't
please tell her Le would get if you
would addicted to it if let me explain
something to you if Lee asked her that
she would throw Lee out of his own house
Lee would be sleeping in the back house
tonight like honey can you just spread
my butt cheeks open and then blow a
street of air no but that's not how you
say you got to sit it down and go listen
we've been doing Edibles for a year and
I got to tell you something Joey's
driving me crazy training training
training training but you can't laugh
like you got to look it straight in the
face and go listen I need a big favor
for me I've never asked you for nothing
nothing I got the midday you got to
break down what you do in the scrub I
got this scrub I got this little lofer
I'm going to go in there I'm going to
take a shower I'm wash my [__] real
good I just want to test it because uh
uh I read in the medical journal that's
really good for your insid and I'll get
high I want you to blow smoke up my ass
it it what's your wife's name it
prevents Pro Paula tell her it prevents
prostate cancer what would you think
she'd say to you I believe if you asked
her just like that like um but you're
closed like closed the whole time you're
closing just do it as you know I love
you Paul right I we've been together I
would take your dog but I can't have
pets you know what I'm saying if it was
up to me your mother would live here
with me Paula I'm asking you for one
thing do it I'm asking you for one thing
do it you're fired right Uncle I'm going
to wash my muffler real good I want you
to you know what the [__] up thing is
I think like she'd be more open to that
than she would be to like anal sex like
that's that's a no no anal I know anal
sex let her have anal sex with your anus
no yeah no that's what she says too no
that's every girl's thing is well what
if
I guys guys ask us to do anal ourselves
it makes me want to do anal to him
listen that's the cool anal sex talk
makes me very nervous I got to be honest
with you we don't have to stay there no
anal sex let's go back to something no
rapes no no you guys speaking of Prisons
there's a prison in Delaware there's a
hostage situation I know I'm worried
about my nephew who works at one of
those prisons he's a guard I think they
they left the guard loose and they got a
counselor and somebody else you know
what they're protesting what
Trump even prisoners are protesting
Trump no they're protesting yeah yeah
they're protesting the living conditions
of the jail and they fear it's going to
get worse because Trump did a bunch of
cuts God damn it so something's going on
so I don't [__] know so yeah my heart
goes out to those people yeah I know
that my dear friend's oldest son is a
prison guard somewhere I I hope it's not
[__] sore in fact I thought somebody
would call by now if it was but nobody
has called I'm sure they're fine yeah
yeah no everybody the chance is that
yeah nobody's nobody's [__] up they
just want they just want um thicker
mattresses listen
man I don't know what the [__] they want
but that's always scary you know when we
shot The Longest Yard we shot The
Longest Yard at the jail that had a
[__]
one of the worst riots in [__] prison
history they even wrote a book book
about it the devil's butcher the butcher
something if you watch The Longest Yard
I if I ever see it with you I can on in
a bar and we're doing comedy I go that
there is a set that there is the prison
they couldn't the prison was left so bad
after the
riot they kept painting the floor
but there was so much blood on the floor
that the color red would still creep up
every year that's how much blood there
was in the floor the blood was
flowing like from all the people they
murdered they cut off the guard's heads
and put them on sticks and [__] yeah
these [__] got down I didn't
know about this either till I shot the
longest y it's not like I sit there at
home and watch Discovery and ghost and
[__] but the place was haunted there was
a deal if you took $1,000 from the
producer you could stay in there
overnight they gave you $11,000 two
people did they couldn't spend the night
in there were they filming you no no no
just go in there we'll lock the door
from the outside
God I like that sh they couldn't make it
Jesus
Christ yeah [__] all that [__] why you
taking me to these dark places [__] I
had a window across from me when I was
growing up like in my bedroom like if I
opened my eyes it was a window and I was
always convinced that there was going to
be like a ghost or a monster or
something just po I put I put like a
Lego piece in front of my closet door
why because the closet went to the attic
and if somebody opened the door and came
in from the attic I would see that the
Lego piece moved how old were you when
you came up with this [__] device
like seven did your dad teach us no I
just thought of
it
that doesn't make any sense because my
closet door led up to the attic right
but the like a piece isn't going to
scare
anybody it's not meant to scare I just
not wanted to see if it moved see if it
moved Lee so some people put a pieces
like like when you go to a hotel and you
carry drugs in the hotel and you put it
do not disturb thing you get a little
piece of tape and you put on the bottom
of the
door why to see if you're doing drugs no
so if somebody opens the door you can
see that they [__] with the tape so you
take a little inch of clear tape when
you check when you close the door you
close the door boom boom you're outside
the hotel there's maids it's a nice
hotel you got 20 kilos of blow in there
let's say you got to go downstairs for 2
minutes usually if you travel like that
you have somebody in the room like a
grandma watching the coke you don't even
stay in that room you stay in another
room on the other side of the hotel but
let's say you're in that predicament
that you're by yourself you have weapons
in
there you put the Do Not Disturb
something you take clear tape you take a
little piece and you put on the bottom
of the door on the
edge so when they walk in they break the
tape you could tell if somebody went in
your door what the [__] are you people
look yeah but they already have the
stuff then you have to set up weapons
because you know sometimes you just want
to know if somebody goes in there
nobody's going to take nothing you just
want to see if a mid goes in there you
know what I'm saying yeah I guess so you
put the tape there no the guy next to me
does yeah you put the [__] tape
in it's a service that the hotel offers
yeah I call the maintenance guy and I go
come here for a second do you travel
with tape I travel with everything I'm
always ready for that count of
surveillance oh now I got to add tape to
my list I got two bags of kind of
surveillance stuff one in my bag and one
in my travel bag I'm like a [__]
green Commando dog oh my God I got so
much [__] in my sleep out your bag you
would I got
speakers why is extra glasses pens an
iPod I got [__] there's always an
edible somewhere that [__]
disguise as a [__] pencil or
something you know what I'm saying I
always got something and I got my sleep
abne machine now I got a smaller machine
so now oh my God guess what oh [__] I
got [__] Jet Blue on sale today in
New York and [__] mint like a
[__] guess what oh [__] guess
what rly one a two boom two I got the
room all to myself you know how we
do dude those lay down mint seats oh
[__] yeah the I don't even sleep
Saturday night but it don't matter
because I'm going to get on the plane
Stone to the gills I will eat a little
breakfast a little threepiece
combination I'm in that bunk by myself
so I put to sleep out the machine right
on the floor I put the [__] thing on
I press go and next thing you know Mr
Diaz Mr Diaz we're Landing in LAX in 20
seconds put a put away your machine I
get up by Joe Tip Top Meo I get in my
little [__] car and I drive home on
the 4:05 at 9:05 I get back in the
morning nothing's even happening on the
Lord's day at
9:05 what the [__] you think you're
dealing with that's the cool you got to
prepare you got to be organized you
understand me yeah I love getting
organized so what have you done
differently have you gotten more grown
up if I last seen you you look more
elegant um I started taking showers all
right no no on the straight side are you
modeling again what are you doing you
look like very uh very busha quaqua you
know what I'm saying as they say oh well
don't criticize my French it's very it's
very contemporary of par Vu quaqua what
are you eating I'm eating a star stop
[__] eating that star because you're
going to black out and you know I don't
want next you know a going to be at
Cosby's house jumping up and down with
his nephews and
[__] he's got nephews your age you know
what I'm saying you don't need that
aggravation you oh [__] imagine that's
like a nightmare Bill Cosby's nephew
starts doing
comedy no Bill Cosby's nephew brings you
over gives you a star death and comes on
your feet when you sleeping that's
[__] up all right well better my feet
then and K and Bill Cosby tapes the
whole thing though what is it with you
on coming on people's feet and neck it's
dog it's something I in the early ' 80s
you my feet have never been comed on
well that's what you get for being a
[__] stiff laroo you got to have
somebody shoot a load on your toe I mean
I've defin definitely given foot jobs
before no I understand just have him
Blast Off on your little heel
right look that youve definitely given
for a job you don't know what life is
till somebody blast a load on your ankle
and [__] that drifts into the shower you
got to get creative you know you're in
the shower you can't just do it regular
missionary style every day you're in the
shower the cat's licking will come off
your foot there's little p of [__] that's
been out there for like 12 minutes the
cat starts licking it after after 8
minutes it goes bad so it becomes
[__] FAL milk whatever the [__] it
becomes yellow and hard and crusted
stained you [__] are crazy it
becomes like the side of a candle you
know when it's dripping and it
solidifies let me give some shout outs
here
real quick
here Le Assan aaran asadorian Joey as a
[__] durian he's Armenian what the
[__] is wrong with that right I'm very
sorry Doug
Le asadorian Shelby Alexis Corey
Leighton Steve
Baka noo MMA congratulations on opening
up your school West Woods Dante gazini
thank you for the album [__] Matt
South Tony zero [__] magu Esquire Dante
I got the album you know I love you I
went and got Eric clapped today but I
left them both in my room on the floor
like a [__] [__] so my apologies I
appreciate the album he sent it to the
store with a CD of debt I almost crashed
the [__] car listening to that stuff
you got people jumping up and down and
trumpets I'm an old man D think I think
Levan asadorian might be a Jewish
Armenian
guy so what what gave you yes sir the
inkling look at my face what gave you
the inkling yes sir that for any reason
I gave a [__] whether he was a Jew
Armenian or you're always on the look
out for Jews If he if he's mixed with
Armenian he could be a d exactly know
what I'm saying no he could be a super
he listens to the podcast so he could be
a tight [__] you that's what I'm
trying to tell you I'm on the lookout
what are you thinking that's cool you're
in no danger you understand me get
together yeah I'm good that's cool do
you have stockings on I do why do you
what what you work at hudas no what the
[__] I saw that before I saw your feet I
do see have stockings on cuz it's chilly
out so who gives a [__] that's what
being in California you can't put put
stockings on it's the cool what's wrong
with stockings it just gives it that bua
effect I thought I thought I thought all
proper women wor stocking [__] that yeah
if you're [__] 48 I know
I got cursed with an old lady's name
what what's that Esther so yeah so rip
off the stockings what are you hiding I
know I mean what's the [__]
problem no I with I have no problem I
wear shorts all the time I no I I didn't
I'm not insulting here but why you got
to show up here with stocking I haven't
stoping about hudas and the bad wings
and I don't normally wear stockings now
you're making me like be embarrassed
about wearing stockings listen you want
to blst that black black stockings I'm
all in but you're going to show up with
Grandma stockings you can't do jelly
[__] you got like the brown crowd I
wasn't prepared to be roasted here no
I'm not roasting you know yeah my me and
my stockings you I'm so embarrassed no
no no I love you I can't believe a lot
of people don't do that that's why
you're so original I like that you're
wearing stockings women come out with
those [__] legs they got a a bruise
on their [__] ankle I got to see it
you know what I'm saying put stockings
on no I have no problem I get bruised
all the time kiding you that's the cool
you don't I'm on my knees all the time
that's the cool listen to me what if you
weit a little star and you're [__]
out there in Planet zero think of where
I'm at right now I don't even know
nothing I don't know nothing don't don't
take me for granted all right I don't
know nothing you don't know nothing
nothing Lee what's going on with you
what are you doing this weekend Shock Me
Oh what what Terrible Things am I doing
this weekend what can I tell you that's
terrible what is it you going to go see
Bad Santa 3 the making of what are you
going to go see now go ahead
I know I know there's a plan this
weekend no I I uh well you talk the
girlfriend to drop it off LAX that's a
start yeah she's going to go down just
Uber her down get no no no no lift her
down there you know on the arm call lift
tell him listen let me lift Mama down
and [__] drop her off St don't come back
till 9:00 and he won two cases
9:00 and you got to win two cases you
know what I'm saying don't come back
till you win two cases I don't give a
[__] 18 years of loss School you went to
France I had to sit at home for a whole
summer jerking off into a [__] donut
hanging out with Joey talking disgusting
things eating Edibles and you want to
show up here don't come back till you
want two cases and you set a federal
[__]
appeal that's what that's and someday
what are you doing you know what you're
doing back to LAX one more time to get
another two [__] cases oh my God
that's how you become an attorney I told
them your girlfriend wants to become an
attorney she can't find the job
you want a g job going down to LAX talk
to those poor [__] Arabian people
that are stuck [__] airport Malaysia
whatever the [__] they're from I don't
[__] know he's bad at 19 I don't know
no more listen people I'm not political
I never claimed to be political I don't
want to be political but this is the
first time in my 54 years like I'm 53
but two weeks who gives a
[__] I'm sitting here going what the
[__] is going on every time I watch TV
this guy this is how long is this going
to last for four years what no no you
could impeach
right well the they people can't make
them impeach listen to me I have been in
this city for 20 years around this in
1995 I signed with an agent that was
very literal like a very literal guy
like he would always said he hated
auditions he hated comedians going on
the road
wow he wanted ComEd no way that's
horrible he wanted comedians to if you
signed with him to at least have a
project that you were always writing
because he had producers that he could
hook you up with and he didn't he
pitched a lot in this
town wow but his one caveat was that you
couldn't leave huh his one thing is that
he didn't want you to leave you couldn't
leave
town
no what was I talking about I don't know
I have to pee so bad well get up and
[__] pee what are you sitting there
like a Mormon for you're sitting there
like you know you know what man take
some paper in there there's no toilet
paper in there which is disgusting I
don't know why I got I got uh tissue
paper but if things are bad you got this
sanitizer here no take the tissue paper
with you I just take the tissue paper
okay go ahead okay where is it just I'll
just make it right there okay don't pay
attention to the camera it's got no
batteries
Lee what the [__] where has this podcast
gone tonight we've gone 18 different
[__] directions nobody knows nothing
I apologize what can I do what can I say
nothing you can't say nothing I'm not
mad at you you're the Captain Kirk of
the Enterprise you know what I'm saying
I'm over here just going for a ride it's
February 1st we figured we're in for a
[__] crazy night tonight we're always
in for a crazy night at the church it's
funny cuz you you called me with that
advice for Paula yesterday and Paula was
in the other room and she was like who
was that I was like who's Joey she like
what did he say I was like huh cuz you
always have to like translate Joey's
advice cuz I think your direct advice
was get your [__] wife down LAX and
but like yeah she it's uh she's excited
about it and it's it's it's fun and it's
weird when you have a job let me ask you
this when you have a job that you like
it's it's kind of hard to think about
the
she doesn't have a job that she L know I
know I know she she went to school for 4
years but here's the beauty ability
she's going to see something she's never
seen before and that's going to bring
something out of her and she'll make her
decisions right there what she wants to
do this and that this is what the best
thing about throwing it to the Wolves
was let it go down there you added a
tremendous point you said she's going to
go down there and meet people she's
going to meet other Attorneys at that
[__] place you know so listen it gets
her out of the house Lee and it gets her
listen me going to an open mic and Paula
going down there and trying to play
attorney it's the same [__]
difference
Lee absolutely it's the same difference
I'm trying to find my voice and Paula is
trying to find hers this is her shot you
go to college let me tell you something
Lee if I went to college for 4 4 years
and then three more and then took the
bar what do you think I'd be talking
about at 5:30 in the morning to you
about this is something I worked for
right you yeah this isn't me on a bus
cracking stupid jokes I would act like a
[__] wild
Savage as soon as I passed the ball
first thing I do is get a [__]
walkie-talkie and a [__] whatever and
every time there's an accident
I'm down there Pro boning [__]
to death on an accident learning along
the way
Lee learning along the way this this is
my style you can't find a job but you're
living with your [__] parents and you
got somebody helping you out believe am
I lying to you no and that's what you
have am I being disrespectful here not
at all the least you could do is get 25
[__] cards got a walkie-talkie
remember last year you and salami were
[__] when whenever somebody would uh
make a left turn and go into somebody's
poll you would get a call to go take a
picture of it and whoever got the
picture of it got $55 in the mail a year
later right same [__] difference
every time a car goes into a pole you
get on your bicycle you go down and you
interview the [__] if the light
ain't working listen let me take you to
the hospital on my bicycle let's get the
paperwork started and listen when you
Sue this [__] I'm gonna do the
that's how you learn guess what Paula
does Tuesday
she walks into machino machino and
machino and says listen I'm an attorney
I got a number I went to USC but you
might not want to hire me but let me
tell you something before I even drop
this bomb on you I'm Spanish I Alo espol
I could do the commercials for you but
and I'm showing up with an
envelope what are you talking about
Miss Paula Paula well I tell you what
I'm [__] talking about I got a guy
that was walking down the street minding
his own
business
whistling you know what I'm saying
whistling listening to an iPod minding
his own business on the streets of LA
and he fell into a
sinkhole that was [__] 5T nothing
happened to him but it wasn't the
sinkhole that killed him he hurt his
ankle he twisted a toe wow it was the
tree that fell on top of his surviv the
sinkhole yeah it was only 4T it's a it's
a tree that fell on top of his [__]
head and now I don't even know what day
it is you know what I'm
saying oh my
God I I don't even know my point was
that well no but you have to put your
the like you have to put yourself in the
situation you have to go intern you have
to go do like I've talked against it at
at a certain point you're done with free
work but when you're first starting out
you're always down with free work yeah
you have to be you're always down with
free work because there's days you might
learn something for free what most
people pay to learn you might might see
somebody do something magical right in
front of your eyes that will open
your mind well and I'm not sure what the
time for of it is for lawyers but from
when you're like for me when I got out
of college after four years of college
the
first year and a half of being an
assistant
editor was just learning everything new
everything was new and I would have to
imagine
a lot of being a lawyer they they can't
teach you at Law School I've even heard
her talk about that so I'm not sure I'm
not sure how long the the learning curve
is but 18 months it has to be at least
listen you're a girl your dad was an
attorney he gets hit by a [__] uh he
gets hit by a accelery truck when you're
11 he was one of the best attorneys of
all time you want to [__] live his
memory you become a [__] attorney
okay okay you know want you get a
[__] job and the guy that runs the
firm has four daughters he's happily
married he sees you he sees something in
you you see something in him and pretty
soon you guys build like a fatherly
[__] Bond okay guess what you going
to work for that [__] he's an
old you just from being around that guy
even if that guy says to you go and
alphabetize these
files there's always a
payoff meanwhile while you're doing what
he told you to do what you think is
feeble what you think is so feeble
you're above like I remember being out
in the field and being a [__] knowt
all you know what I'm saying and like me
doing this this is [__] I didn't you
know I didn't come here to do this but
he's saying you don't understand for you
to do that you got to do this first so
you understand
that you know and you have to do how
long do you have to do this for a
[__] year until you really see what
we're talking about then I can come back
to you and go it's 38° I need the mud to
[__] dry in 345 minutes and you're
making concrete or something like that
you know I'm taking out of content but
when an attorney what Paul is going to
learn in 18 months is going to be
invaluable whether she goes to the
prosecutor's office or a [__] badass
attorne like if you're around Cochran
let's say you get a job with like God
forbid whatever his [__] name is God
Rest his soul Johnny Cochin he
died that guy when he when he tried the
OJ Tri he was at his best can you
imagine being around that guy you're his
intern for a year and a half during the
OJ trial you're going to see all the
paperwork all the Motions all the
Motions to suppress you're going to see
all this stuff how much are you going to
[__] learn and that but what kind of
education is that huge huge huge huge
and but you said the word the perfect
word you said was C cuz that's what
you're going to do you're not going to
you don't really get to ask questions I
would you don't get to really talk yes
you do Lee I don't know you know what
Lee at 9
fucking3 at 9:30 at night you know you
know me Lee you know I'm going to be in
that office if I'm a [__] Jew and I'm
making it [__] work for me you know
me dog I work all hours I get up with
insomnia I go work an hour who gives a
[__] at 9:30 when Paula says good night
Phil
and she goes good night Paul uh be safe
is Lee waiting for you outside yes he is
thank you for asking that's when Paul
says can I ask you a
question
today why did you file that
motion to move whatever and this guy
will go first off the motion's not going
to fly I sent it out with judge Paxton
judge Paxton [__] hates me but I did
that for a reason I did that to throw
them off here to make them think I'm
changing courts or whatever or venue
everything is a move with those high
priced attorneys when an attorney looks
to you and he goes give me five grand
and you're like man that's expensive and
Austin there's another guy that goes ask
to come here for a second that problem
you had you're looking at some prison
time listen to me you're going to do
four years in jail that's you're going
to lose your
career okay you might come out a hero or
you might come out of convict we're not
going to know why are we going to throw
the dice you're too young right now to
go to prison what
if give me 100 Grand cash and I get you
six years probation do two years
straight stay out of the clubs don't go
[__] drinking don't get caught doing
nothing and after two years I'll get it
all dropped and it goes away donate a
show to breast cancer and go talk to
some chicks who've been kicked in the
head 15 times and we'll get you off your
thing what would you do es cool you
follow but you'll see the difference
you'll see the difference you'll see how
this guy go okay let's go to work
tomorrow next thing you know you're
getting this paperwork and he's
requesting this [__] and doing this [__]
and you're like wow and there's there's
Parts you get mad at them you're like
this [__] gave $100,000 [__]
dollars and now I'm going to end up
[__] going to
jail and all a sudden you go like the
preliminary hearing and he rips a
[__] rabbit out of his
[__] and you're like oh
[__] oh [__] I didn't even see this
coming I've been watching laan order for
20 [__] years and I didn't see this
coming and all a sudden again he takes
you on a [__] six-month tour but your
life is on the line you know what I'm
saying your life is on the line you want
to know what's going on he's not going
to tell you he's not going to tell you
till it's trial time or time to [__]
negotiate your [__] uh plea agreement
that's when you get blown the [__] away
that's when you go in there and he
breaks it down for you this is why I did
this if you went in there as this you're
going to end up as this this is and you
sit there and you go thank you thank you
for not robbing me you know what I'm
saying this is the payoff I wanted
everything you told me would happened
happened you with me as the cool or you
some [__] where else seeing stars and
little bunny somebody dropped me off at
the Little Dipper good that's I say good
[__] A Little Dipper let me give let me
read some stuff here and we'll get you
out of
here I'm really excited about this one
let me tell you what happened guys about
uh September with all that [__] those
tours and the weeks before the
CD I
uh I threw out my back I don't know how
the [__] I did it and I didn't know what
to
do I didn't call I didn't uh call around
or nothing like that so
uh I went to this place called
back uh whatever I don't even know what
the [__] it was and I went in there and
it was uh it was pretty [__] damn
good I went there twice and they hooked
me up you know they gave me a massage
and then they they put you through a
chiropractor which I'd never experienced
before and your insurance pays for it
they put you to like a wow your
insurance pays for it s
yeah yeah like a 45 minute massage I
mean I think the the thing is uh
$49 and saag picks up 28 of it or
something I'm good I'm good I gave her a
20 tip what do I give a [__] I'm good
you know what I'm saying sa picked up
half of it I'm still going to give it to
her off the top so the girl gives you
massage then the chiropractor comes in
right next to she puts you on the
Chiropractic table she [__] hit some
place on my back everything she put tape
on my back to hold the treatment she
adjusted my neck it was tremendous I
went there twice and that's the cool
before that I had never ever ever really
gotten a massage you know my wife rubs
my shoulders and stuff like that but uh
I got this call a few weeks ago
chiropractors are awesome aren't they
well all that stuff you know but yeah
but I got this call a few weeks ago to
uh to you know if I was interested in
talking about a massage company that
would come on and uh and I read what
they did and I tell you something I was
blown away you could order a masseuse
online and Tipper online one two three
they come to your house on time
effective great reviews I said yeah I
love to work with them you know so this
Valentine's Day don't fight the crowds
with a big night out don't worry about
making reservations turn your home into
a luxury spa with your own private
massage with Zeal here's an idea to make
Valentine's easy get a couple's massage
night at home with a private licensed
massage therapist from Zeal it's an easy
way to win Valentine's Day bring the
massage to you with couples Mage from
Zeal just go to zeal.com or go on zal's
iPhone or Android app that's Zeal spent
Ze
l.com and select top local license and
pre-screen massage therapist choose your
favorite technique gender preference
time and location of your M Massage Zeal
will send one of their 8,000 licensed
massage therapists with a massage table
music and supplies to give you a f Star
Massage scheduling booking and payment
is fast and easy even the tip is
included 7 days a week 365 days a year
and a zom massage therapist can be in
your door as in as little as one hour
privacy convenience quality Comfort
that's what you get with your massage On
Demand with Zeal find out for yourself
why Zeal has been featured the Wall
Street Journal New York Times Vogue and
Good Morning America to help you get
started our listeners can get $25 off
the first massage by using promo code
church at checkout. zal spelled
z.com and then make sure to click add
promo code at checkout to use my code
church
curch right now go to zeal.com or on
zal's iPhone or Android app and get a
special offer when you try Zeal today
right now enter promo code church and
check out to get a $25 off in your home
on demand massage who's better than you
okay listen it's Valentine's Day what
are you you're going to go to a
restaurant you going to give her some
[__] dead rose you're going to give
her some dead rose what are you going to
do do the same thing you do every year
you know what do something different go
to the supermarket get some fried
chicken go home schedule the massuse
when was the last time you ate fried
chicken and had a massage I'm massuse
come to your door you need to treat
yourself oh please you know I'm Savage
you know I'm a Savage and heat I love I
love getting massages no they're
tremendous massages getting massage is
like just making sure your body
continues to like work right you know
you go out there you're running all your
errands and all this [__] you got to
like make sure your body like
flows like you got to knead it out it's
like your body's like a piece of bread
with pretzels in it I hear you right now
go to zeal.com or on zal's iPhone or
Android app and get a special offer when
you try Zeal today enter promo code
church and check out to get $25 off your
first inhome on the man massage you're
going to love this stuff number two one
of my all-time favorites right here as
Le told you in the beginning the days
are back the days are walking around you
don't know what's wrong your [__]
itchy but not really your underwear is
tucked in there but something don't it's
all over
bed are back baby in home portable
bedday sent right to your home takes
what to install it Lee 20 minutes tops
20 minutes tops and if Lee could install
it anybody could install it
installations so let me tell you
something what is it clip onto the bowl
it Clips onto the bowl easy peasy you
just take those the bowl the lid off
like it just screws off under the bottom
or however the your uh toilet lid comes
off put that uh the
hello tushy down put the lid back on
it's easy and then it's a little couple
they you have a little adapter on the uh
for the where the water goes into the
toilet it t yeah it takes 20 minutes
people you have no idea you're sitting
there at your desk all day you know what
happens to the ass you get mold milde
hemorrhoids bacteria those days are done
cuz now you could stop by the house and
you got the portable B and you're living
like a doctor these things get shipped
to your house they got a 60-day
guarantee and now they're doing a
Valentine's Day special well they're
going to send you two
bday free shipping to your house that's
it two B days one for him one for her
you put one in the garage so he can go
down there and [__] himself to debt and
he could wash his ass and light a candle
and a box of [__] matches and one for
you upstairs in the bathroom you know
with the pink carpeting with the candles
on everything's beautiful listen the
barber strand there you are with cold or
hot water hitting your [__] like a
doctor why be a [__] orphan get two
for Valentine's Day and hellotushy.com
I'll throw you free shipping go to
hellotushy.com right now and press in
church bam get 10% off your order you
understand me get two of them get free
shipping and if you don't give it to
somebody you like you look at somebody
and you go that dude's [__] smells
bam that's your victim do something good
for them you look at somebody like a
woman and go you know what she's
attractive but I could tell a [__]
stinks like 10 dead [__] Iranians
bam that's who you give a hell of tushy
to you know what I'm
saying I went for the office I don't
know if I if I if I worked in an office
why not yeah no the whole [__] deal
guys this the deal of a lifetime I love
them I love them as a where the water
come from the it just comes from the the
water that's going to go into the toilet
it just a from the inside the toilet
that goes up no it's it's it's your it's
the water line that's going into the
toilet they have a splitter and the
splitter goes and it's and now you
connect it back in so you can flush and
then the other one goes to the to the
hushi and then that's when you do the
the little dial see I know how [__]
cool is that dog you're going to order
one when you get home go to hell
tushi.com right now and press in charge
and get 10% off your order or two of
them for Valentine's Day special till
the 14th and get free shipping seriously
guys do it this is it this is it you can
dip your nut sack in it it's beautiful
and you got a 60-day money back
guarantee all right I want to thank Zeal
give back to the church zeal.com right
now right and I want to thank hello
tushi hellotushy.com and I want to thank
uh my girl Esther C for coming on and on
it always a [__] pleasure I want to
thank an it for being the Captain Kirk
of the Enterprise always go to hon it
and get 10% off by pressing in church
bam and get direct to your house whether
it's the shroom Tech the uh the hemp
Force protein I love all that [__]
stuff have a great week and when you're
done L the church you can listen to coup
and the Gang go listen to coup and the
Gang on iTunes all right Lee I love you
[__] sucker love you too you didn't tell
me what you're going to do so that means
I don't want to I'm not doing [__] I
guess all right stay black have a great
weekend guys I love you oh Nashville
yeah tomorrow [__] don't forget
Valentine's Day I'm at [__]
Flappers up here in b
9:00 show all right but this weekend
Nashville tomorrow night 8:00 show stay
[Music]
black if she don't get the
away
she
[Music]
like you not it
back she got
[Music]
look she look at
you
let she got the
[Music]
look she keep the motor
clean can't believe
me
[Music]
she
she looking Lou
L she turn on juice
boy turn
on
[Music]
she she
look she got
the she got
kill she got
[Music]
kill she
got
[Music]
she
[Applause]
[Music]
see razor
shot it's in good
[Music]
away like a
cat you get
game you might not make it
[Music]
back she got the look you
she got
the
got she got
[Music]
good
down